en el último vídeo vimos tres ejemplos
distintos que en realidad es un poco de
repaso de algunas técnicas sobre
factorización y también vimos cuando
aplicar cada una
vimos en el primer ejemplo el proceso de
cómo reconocer un factor común y cómo
factorizar lo en el segundo ejemplo
vimos que primero tendríamos un factor
común tenemos como factor común al 4
pero después de eso usamos la técnica
más común donde dijimos cuáles dos
números suman el coeficiente del término
de grado 1 y que a su vez su producto
sea el término constante y justo así
factor izamos esta expresión y en el
tercer ejemplo de nuevo empezamos
factorizar un valor común que en este
caso fue el 3 y nos dimos cuenta que
podríamos llegar a la respuesta usando
la misma técnica que el segundo
ejercicio o que podríamos reconocer esto
como un polinomio de segundo grado que
es un cuadrado perfecto
y de ambas formas llegamos al resultado
así que qué te parece si hacemos otros
tipos de ejemplos otros ejemplos que
requieran otros tipos de técnicas así
que vamos a empezar con este digamos que
tenemos la expresión 7x cuadrada menos
63 y como siempre pausa el vídeo y ver
si puedes resolver la ok
intencionalmente designe este tipo de
ejemplos para que no tengamos un factor
común que en este caso es el 7 todo es
divisible por 7 así que sí factor izamos
un 7 vamos a tener 7 que multiplican am
x cuadrada y después tengo menos 9 y
ahora seguramente de una manera
inmediata
vas a reconocer este como una diferencia
de cuadrados esto es lo mismo que x
elevado al cuadrado menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado ahora si esta idea de
diferencia de cuadrados te es
completamente ajena te encargo que ver
los vídeos sobre cómo factorizar una
de cuadrados en la canaca de mi bien
nosotros sabemos que una diferencia de
cuadrados se puede factorizar como bueno
aquí tengo el 7 y después me quedarían x
3 que multiplican a x menos 3 y es más
déjeme poner esto de otro color 7 que
multiplica a x + 3 y esto a su vez
multiplica a x menos 3 es decir estos
salen de x cuadrado menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado ahora una cosa que vale la pena
recalcar es que esto no es tan distinto
a la técnica que estábamos viendo en el
vídeo anterior si nos enfocamos en x
cuadrada en 29 podemos ver esto
exactamente igual que bueno fíjate x
cuadrada por acá voy a poner al menos 9
y en medio de ellos 2 voy a poner
bueno más 0 x y en este caso decir para
que dos números su producto es menos 9 y
su suma es cero bueno si tengo el
producto de menos 9 recuerda eso quiere
decir que deben de tener signos
distintos
uno debe de ser positivo y el otro es
negativo ya que recuerda si tienen el
mismo signo el producto sería positivo
entonces tenemos dos números de signos
distintos y bueno 9 sólo tiene tres
factores uno tres y nueve puede ser 193
y tres pero si sumamos menos uno más
nueve o menos 91 eso en definitiva no te
da cero y ahora observa si sumamos menos
33 eso sí te da 0 por lo tanto los dos
números que debemos de estar buscando
deben de ser menos 3 y 3 y por lo tanto
esto es x menos 3 por x 3 una vez más
solo me estoy enfocando en lo que hay
adentro del paréntesis justo aquí y si
pones el 7 al frente obtienes justo la
misma expresión a la que llegamos pero
también si reconoces esto como una
diferencia de cuadrados entonces puedes
encontrar la solución un poco más rápido
muy bien así que qué te parece si
hacemos uno más ahora voy a hacer el
siguiente
12 que es cuadrada + 7 x + 3 y ahora
bien en general cuando tengo un
coeficiente que no sea 1 en mi término
de segundo grado entonces voy a buscar
un factor común pero observa 7 no es
divisible entre 2 ni tampoco lo es 3
entonces no podemos usar todas las
técnicas que hemos visto antes por lo
que si tenemos una situación como ésta
la pista es que factor hicimos por
agrupación y podemos decir que todo lo
que hemos visto hasta ahorita de hecho
es en cierta manera factorización por
agrupación porque cuando factorizar por
agrupación dices ok
hay alguna forma de pensar en dos
números que al sumarlos me den el
coeficiente del término del primer grado
es decir a más veces igual a 7 y que a
por b en lugar de decir que sean igual a
3 en realidad pensamos que sean igual a
3 por el coeficiente en el término de
segundo grado a por b tiene que ser
igual
es por dos y si lo piensas siempre
hicimos esto pero en los otros casos
teníamos que el coeficiente del término
del segundo grado era 1 entonces al
final 1 por el término constante era
simplemente el término constante pero de
forma más general lo único que vamos a
hacer es tener a x de igual al término
constante por el coeficiente del término
de segundo grado y justo esto lo probé
en el vídeo de introducción a la
factorización por agrupación en ese
vídeo explicamos por qué esto funciona
así que tal vez en un principio pienses
que esto es magia pero realmente tiene
un sentido por una razón matemática por
ahora vamos a darlo por hecho para poder
aplicar esta técnica entonces pensemos
en dos números que sumados de en siete y
su producto sea 6 bueno observa deben de
tener el mismo signo porque tenemos un
producto positivo y deben de ser ambos
positivos porque la suma también es
positiva
así que si pensamos en
a ver 1 y 6 y 16 parece que funciona
porque 1 667 y 1 por 666 así que para
factorizar por agrupación vamos a
separar este término este 7x entre a y b
entonces ojo observa vamos a escribir
esto como 2x cuadrada más 6x más x + 3 y
como puedes ver el 7x lo acabamos de
dividir entre 6 x y 1 x y en general el
ejercicio consiste en cómo romper este
coeficiente de hecho esta es la parte
central del ejercicio y lo útil de todo
esto es que ahora esencialmente podemos
aplicar la propiedad inversa a la
propiedad distributiva digamos a hacer
la propiedad distributiva hacia atrás es
decir vamos a factorizar lo más que se
pueda de los dos primeros términos
observa lo más que podemos factorizar de
estos dos primeros términos es
simplemente 2x ya que 2x cuadrada y 6x
son ambos divisibles entre 2 x entonces
si factor izamos este 2x de estos dos
términos voy a obtener bueno 12 que es
cuadrada entre 2x es lo mismo que x y 6x
entre 2 x es lo mismo que 3 y bueno
tengo esto más y bueno aquí tengo un
caso excepcional donde m en x 3
no tengo ninguna factorización no tengo
en ningún factor común entonces aquí
solamente tengo x 3 y lo voy a escribir
de hecho voy a poner un paréntesis aquí
porque aunque sabemos que esto es
equivalente escribirlos en el paréntesis
con el uso del paréntesis vamos a ver
algo más porque observa esta vez podemos
factorizar de estos 21 x + 3
qué pasa si hago esto bueno tendría lo
siguiente tengo x + 3 que multiplica y
ahora en lo que tengo de verde me
quedaría 12
x sin factor hizo x + 3 me quedo con 2x
simplemente y luego si factor hizo x 3
de x 3 bueno simplemente me quedo con 1
x + 3 que multiplica a 2 x + 1 y hemos
acabado entonces tenemos todas estas
técnicas y tal vez la más difícil sea
esta factorizar por agrupación pero digo
difícil entre paréntesis porque todo lo
que hicimos anteriormente fue en
realidad una variación o un caso
especial de la factorización por
agrupación y como puedes ver solo
consisten en dos números que sumados
desde en el coeficiente de x es decir
dos números que te den el coeficiente
del término de primer grado y el
producto vaya a ser igual al producto
del término constante y del coeficiente
del término del segundo grado y después
si lo haces adecuadamente te encontrarás
con algo fácil de factorizar de hecho en
este ejemplo pasó algo interesante
porque tuvimos que reconocer que
x 3 tiene un coeficiente de 1 de manera
implícita para así poder factorizar un x
3 de ambos términos y al hacerlo
llegamos a este 2x + 1 y bueno si
realmente te sientes cómodo con este
arsenal de técnicas que acabamos de
desarrollar entonces no habrá alguna
cuadrática que no puedas factorizar
ahora bien francamente sin nada de esto
te funciona entonces vas a poder
utilizar la fórmula cuadrática que
próximamente vamos a aprender y esta
fórmula nos va a ayudar a resolver
ecuaciones cuadráticas